oh my god he has a but he has my whole
[Music]
for driving on the freeway now I'm not
terrified anyway what's your guys
favorite dessert my favorite dessert is
ice cream I love like the tops of
muffins the muffin top see what's wrong
with you I don't like the bottom
just the top but that's not a dessert
yeah really that is a dessert it's I'm
sorry
yeah I'm not like a chocolate muffin
muffin is for breakfast my friends
[Music]
today we are in honey and butter and
this is a bakery that specializes in
macarons and creature macarons we
started three years ago as a team
husband wife we we love cute stuff
kawaii or animals or any anime
characters anything that is really cute
my wife she was my girlfriend a couple
days and she visited me we just like
come together and figured out what we
want to do and she loved making macarons
she had experience with that and I said
no problem we can do it let's give it a
try oh my god oh my god here's the but
he has my whole he's beautiful
I like I feel a physical pain like
thinking about eating this there's like
chocolate filling I think oh yeah that's
where the flavor is
I just watched oh yeah did I feel bad oh
god I ate the butthole I see it there's
a little chunk of butthole yeah I would
like definitely give this out at a party
because people would love me they love
to eat it
oh my gosh it's a unicorn well that's
adorable
this is crazy the artwork on this is
just fantastic I just go for it I'm a
hundred percent certain these are two
pancakes that they let get a little too
fluffy no it's so weird you know like
when you see like Gatorade flavors or
something you call them blue or red this
tastes like pink I don't know how to
describe it
my first thought when I took a bite was
just kidding
I can just dip this in some maple syrup
call it a day
get some flapjacks looks like an
elephant a little tiny elephant baby
I feel bad eating it because somebody
worked so hard on it you know somebody
was just like ah a little sleepy
elephant creation like this will be Boop
it tastes like french toast like my
bizarre thing actually house like little
french toast cereal in it i love it the
ears come off as like a little like five
five sleepy elephants what's the rating
idea
[Music]